hello guys my name is Chan welcome to
episode 21 of the Sparky imagined series
in which we make a game engine from
scratch in C++ so today we're going to
be talking about extending our font
functionality a little bit to include
different fonts and whatnot so right now
if we launch our game to just see where
we left off we left off with this stuff
we had FPS printing you know using a
certain font and it was all good but the
problem is our current workflow for
drawing this stuff is as follows labels
we only specify this is all we see so
remember main dot cpp is like the it's
like an example game so this is
everything everything that gets exposed
by the engine everything that isn't
internally in the engine can be visible
here so anything that we can't do from
main means it's not actually exposed by
the engine which is it could be a bad
thing right so anyway what I'm saying is
when we create this label we give it a
few parameters right we give it text we
give it an axe and why like any other
renderable and we give it a color but we
don't actually give it a font at all
ever right it doesn't have a font it
should probably write because what if I
want to draw it in a different font
right now we've only got one font
essentially and it's it's the source or
what was actually a source Pro sands or
something let me just check documents
projects source source sans Pro so
that's the font way using for this
current printing right and we're
shipping that with the engine so that
being said that's kind of what's going
on right what if I want to use a
different font well right now you can't
because the way we've set it up well you
can but the way we've set it up is in
the batch render itself we're loading
the font in right and that's cool and
stuff but it's not something we want to
do because we want to make a font class
a font object which has and which has an
Atlas and a font that's what we want to
do and then we want to be like actually
use this font instead and the best thing
is about this
is that once we make a font manager
class which is just going to be like an
array of fonts but you can search them
by name for example this is going to be
a really simple thing so we might go
something like label FPS whatever and
when we make the label we might specify
something like well we have a color and
we'll have something like Arial done
right which is which is going to make it
really easy okay and we in fact Arial
maybe in the size or in fact we can
probably just specify an actual font
object so without further ado let's go
into our source files under graphics and
we'll create a new item called font dot
CPP and similarly under header files
we'll also create other graphics and you
filed it is called font dot H which I
had a file and I'm going to close pretty
much everything else well we've got a
lot of stuff open okay so probably once
that had a file name space
Sparky name space graphics so font so a
font is going to have a few things a
font is namely going to have exactly
what our batch renderer has so in terms
of these things so these two Atlas these
again shouldn't be part of this at all
it they the the rendering the the the
renderer shouldn't have such low level
knowledge about fonts okay so we'll
include a free type GL which i think is
over here and again we'll get rid of
that so we're not going to expose
anything to it it'll be better that way
oh no we yeah
I'm not going to expose anything to it
so I'm going to keep the font class
implementation specific it's going to be
better that way for sure anyway now
we've got this
where were we in batch render or wearing
the same old wearing the same wearing
the same thing oh I probably would have
made it yes
that's annoying okay so it made the file
in the wrong place yeah let's go back it
here because it doesn't know the actual
setup of these files font is not in the
right location let's scroll up and pop
it into graphics okay so now that we're
in graphics this should work yes but
it's not so this is what that's weird
so back to pump or and into no wait
supposed to go yes indeed state what
that's that's oh that's that is wrong
that's because it's um oh goodness me it
doesn't I don't think it's like yay love
it see this is why Visual Studio is a
bit annoying and that's why I like using
the show all files thing it probably
still thinks let's just remove this so
we'll go into will go into yeah here are
fonts lets okay so they are mm let's
include these in project okay there we
go so it's a bit annoying anyway um
we've got our font things yeah we'll
also have stuff like like size so this
is probably an unsigned int okay now we
can start our public stuff so fonts when
we create a new font we want to do a few
things we probably want to take in a
file name right now we'll just take it
into the string
so we'll taking a filename and so we'll
have a M file name
and we'll also have a STD string which
is name so we give it a name we give it
a file name and we give it a size oops
okay so let's include string okay so
there we go so there's our font
constructor let's just think of a few
things we might want to do like get name
for example
and get filename this might be good for
debugging and whatnot I'm getting making
getters for all that all those things
and then guess size might be useful as
well
yeah constant don't need a reference
there getsize alright so if you get as
we need to make some getters for these
objects probably again we're done we
don't really if we the best thing to do
in this case is actually going to be to
go to our batch renderer dot cpp and
actually just look through it okay so
this is yeah we'll copy that stuff in a
minute but look through what we actually
need okay so let's go do this we have to
look through what we actually need so
you can see we need a texture ID right
we need we need to actually live so we
need to somehow grab glyphs this is
where it becomes a bit difficult because
and remember the reason we get the
glyphs is very straightforward we only
get the glyphs to retrieve a few
information about the cliff's such as
the kerning the offsets and the width
and all of the texture stuff and the
advanced X in the scale Y yeah okay
there's a lot of stuff I'm not going to
make it I might make it in the future I
might make it API independent but right
now it is going to be API dependent
because it's just going to be way too
much work and there's no reason to do it
because I don't think we'll ever use
because I don't think we'll ever use
oops I meant after to jail I don't think
we'll ever use any other font thing
anyway all right cool so now all we need
to do is implement stuff like the
constructor so in the CPP file for font
just over here let's include fonts grab
our namespaces
okay so font font let's grab our
parameters
okay so we'll set M name names this is
just any name that you give the font I
probably have some kind of documentation
as well eventually but not now
and file name name of file name and size
oops sighs okay so this needs to do this
stuff so let's cut this and pop it over
here yes so this stuff will probably say
the same and then this stuff is what
will be a bit different so I think what
I'll do I think what I'll do is I will
yes this is looking pretty good we might
make a default constructor so what if
you're like I just want the default font
or whatever so yeah so we might do
something like I don't know this what
this might be useful right so we'll give
it a size all right and in fact we'll
specify a name this would get this will
actually be very confusing for people
instead we'll have probably some kind of
great if all I don't know I won't deal
with default font develop fonts for now
if you want fun you have to explicitly
let it there'll be a system font that
get forget the gets loaded by the actual
game engine if people wanted to fall
font they can just do this okay and then
this has to be the file name and I'll
save that for now okay and the C string
or the file man okay cool so there we go
we've got our font setup now what we
need let's go back to batter and row
what do we need so we clearly need to
get an ID so what we're going to do is
it's going to draw string from a bunch
of things on side in color it needs to
have a font though so Const font font so
we want to do stuff we're going to be
able to do stuff like font darts get ID
yeah so let's implement that feature by
feature I think so back here we will
include font in fact font will include
this so we can get rid of that so
include font alphabetical order maybe
and then we'll do self those external
here there we go nice
so back out here in font so we need get
ID so in line Const
this is like an Evangelion to but get ID
and I think it's the unsilent
return m ft atlas ID what is that
exactly there it's a non silent
beautiful okay
so this is now good ID oh I need a mic
it Const
okay then we need that's the same thing
want a kid ID okay so then we need to
get glyphs I'll make a gate cliff ah no
wait okay so this is where my exposure
to this kind of stops so I'll have a
will have a few things we'll have in
line this thing get ft fonts so free
type Chalfont ft GL font I'll call it
Const and this would return m ft fonts
I'll just call it empty phones free time
font and then Atlas do we need that do
we need that at all actually the Alice I
think we do yes we do because we need
white do we know we don't need the Alice
okay that makes things easier
okay so now
we do this oh and a few things that I
didn't do I did
so that returns the point it good just a
point up all good in the hood
so font equal arm ft font equals font
yet I have T font
okay now that stock is replaced there
and we've got the glyph stuff and
everything else is good in the hood okay
great that's it that's really all we
needed to do and we've got a color and a
font will yes o color color is separate
from font that's kind of important I
would say so we've got yeah so font text
position is that Gore or is that a good
order of parameters we can probably set
a default color as well if we wanted to
so we got the so let's just look let's
just
I'm the show I'm just kind of thinking
about how we would call something like
this so for making a label for example
or factual string so it gets cold fonts
hello
like the X&Y for example and then a
color
what do we want this to be first or last
that yeah I think that might look a bit
better actually
so public haunts the font just before
the color and then we've got this
position here as well okay cool
that looks good so they cut the fonts
details are grouped and then this is
just the actual stuff we're drawing out
like that so let's go back into the
header file we'll add that in and we'll
have to go here and add that in yeah
okay and which probably included font
yeah instead so false and then we won't
have to do it in batter and uh batch
renderer rather done okay cool in fact
render whole tree day we shouldn't need
a them because we should have that so
I'm just sorting out those are the
render bowls all but this is yeah we
can't included that that's right
what render pulse no my renderer today
why all cause of submit yes because it
was submit that makes more sense
okay
okay so all is good in the hood I'm
actually operating in release mode oh
it's not good in the hood okay so this
is the label stuff so this is this
becomes a bit different now so label
will have a font there needs a font so
fonts fonts probably have a pointer to a
font and it won't have a destruct it
won't destroy the font as well so label
will take in all this stuff and then
font font why did we why is this here
why are we doing this that's so weird
what what what is going on here is it
oh that's right we're losing in I was
confused M font I didn't call it that M
font equals font we can just do that in
the other all right cool everything
looks good so then here we just passed
an font in and we draw string all right
cool that's something pretty good I
think maybe not no there weren't a comms
pointer huh wait did they Wow no they
shouldn't really oh that's right it's
hanging in a constant reference so
that's a bit of mine maybe we should
start it as a reference then now we need
to store as a pointer hmm okay that's
fine we can just do that doesn't matter
really okay um let's just build this and
see a few hours we get from the usage
errors like right here so this is the
FPS so now we can specify font so we can
be like let's grab a font so this is why
we need a font manager but font font
equals new font so we'll call it Ariel
it will be well actually it's not Ariel
this all sounds pro right yeah
they can call whatever you want then
this is the actual file name and then
you get VA beside like 32 and then you
like fonts all right and then that
should work no it goes next to the nicer
yeah all right so we should get the same
results and we do fantastic cool so now
let's make a form manager because that
would make more sense
so in graphics I'm going to make a so
font manager is again just something
that stores a bunch of fonts so font
manager dot H and font manager dot CPP
so pragma once include font manager ok
and then we'll go ahead and sneak in too
well so font is kind what's gonna do but
we'll just grab this
yeah I wish video wouldn't do that it's
a bit annoying okay
so class font manager this is one of
those static things by the way this
isn't something that you make an
instance of this has yeah this is just
something that kind of exists statically
so what we'll have is a private static
STD vector
Alfonse basically that's all it's it's
pretty basic we'll we'll see how it
works and I'm actually I'm literally
creating this um alright so rather than
my video cut off on what I am quoting
this on the fly by the way so I've got
no idea if this will work well it will
but what I'm saying is if I go and
change the design multiple times whilst
coding this is because I'm doing this
stuff live and I don't know so M fonts
so this is the main kind of thing so we
should add this in here
okay now that's done let's sew font
manager okay so it will have a I guess
it'll have a private constructor them
because it's not really meant to be
constructed at all it might have
something like in it and clean I don't
know we'll see
so font manager so we'll have something
like void add font font will have void
remove we don't really need to remove
let's not have a remove let's have ADD
and then we'll have void so void like
destroy well should we call it like a
shutdown thing
hmm clean or something I don't know
and that sounds dangerous there and this
is a real funny static voice I'm
thinking well like hmm cuz gel adobe
would have something like what didn't
use again I'm just thinking I terminate
so we don't want manager terminate I
don't know clean so clean will actually
just get rid of everything so this is
what you need to do at the end this is
like our destructor it's gonna be called
clean so yes and then this is private to
make sure that no one can construct a
file manager because you shouldn't you
should never do that so avoid font
manager and so M fonts pushback fonts oh
then we have to get get that's kind of
the most important thing isn't it and
then we have clean which just goes for
in I equals 0 I is less than M fonts dot
size I plus plus and we should have
really something like this but for
textures by the way but M fonts I so
delete and font size okay good so now
that we've got that I wish we definitely
need to do something like that into this
right at the fonts by the way I didn't
think of that and we'll do that in a
minute
ok so static before it yet in fact we'll
probably overload the that'll be
interesting actually
hmm we can overload the like beam Dex
operators the subscript operator will
see so get
STDs string name I'm waiting no I want
to copy it
it's going to return a font pointer so
what this does is very simple
we'll say yeah fun so no wait manager so
it's going to go through we can just use
the for each loop here so for font font
fonts will say that if font get name
equals name return fonts return no
awesome I'll point up okay there we go
so this is a quick little algorithm that
will just linearly search all our fonts
for the name that we specify and return
the appropriate one or a null pointer if
that's not the case I'm not sure if I
want to do this maybe return a default
font instead maybe for debug it will
return a null pointer and for release
mode or something it will return like an
actual font just because yeah I get but
then I guess you could check for it and
say that there's a few different ways to
do is any way that something pretty good
we can get fonts by name we can't get
them right by memory address we might
want to have this we might want to have
get name and size
so I'll do on the side and instead okay
so what this will do is the same except
it'll also check to save font in fact I
think if we do this check faster which
is this fact and just check first it'll
probably be faster no 100% sure and
really smart but it should be okay cool
and I'll add that to the to do okay cool
so there we go now we're checking size
and yeah because again this will just
return the first song with the name but
not the size okay that is looking pretty
good so the idea is very simple at the
end so we need to use font manager
basically so at the end and I'll just
include this for now here you need to
make sure that you like whether delete
protector you call font manager clean
that'll just delete everything I guess
you don't have to do that but you will
probably want to and then and then we
will sew this font that we created for
example it's new font and we've given it
a name source sounds pro we can cut that
out and we just go font manager and that
okay cool so we give it a new font and
then over here we simply call font
manager gets source sans pro like that
and that should just functionally work
the same as it did before
because it does okay but what's new is
that again it's something that if we use
a font manager instead so whenever
constructing that and then you can
probably say I want a size 32 as well
and it will get you that we could make
something that it will construct all the
sizes we need so we could make get this
is another thing that I'm probably going
to leave up to you guys so if you want
to leave a comment below on the YouTube
video I'm also live-streaming this so
people in the stream feel free to
contribute but I'll probably be checking
the comments in the YouTube video
whether or not we won't get to make the
font if it doesn't exist obviously can't
make a font based on name but for
example if you specify form that it does
find so it does find that but it doesn't
find the size of 32 maybe it should make
it because it's got the because from
this you can get the file name and check
that stuff out obviously because if it
finds the font object font has get file
name font has get file name so it can
look at that and then reload that and
basically construct a new font based on
that file name with the same name but
with the different size so that's
something else that could be done but
that looks pretty good so let's add a
few things for label a few new things
for label so let's make label take in a
font so let's make it take in a string
another cost reference
so this is going to do the same thing as
the other constructor except it will
actually just go a font manager I get
name and similarly we should probably
make one that works for size as well but
this is just a few things that will
probably make your life a bit easier so
we're not specifying sizes at all so
string font int size and then we've got
color so back here let's copy that size
which we'll just add that here and then
of course it's not named it's font and
all its good in the hood so there we go
that should work so if I instead of
having to use this now I should be able
to just say both that fighting exists if
it doesn't it'll crash with a null
pointer it should probably print
something at least right and then it and
then I can also do that which will look
a bit cleaner so there you go it's up to
you but if we do something like this
something that won't be equal then it
will just crash with a bad access or
something yeah well access violation is
the same as bad access because it's null
so what we should do is probably render
using a default font as long as our
specified one is null so we'll make
label do that and we won't make renderer
do that
so if basically if it tries to do this
and if M we could just do something
actually like validate font
because we're going to do it twice
that's all that's why I'm going to make
it into a function okay so we're going
to validate the fonts am I going to say
that if M font equals null pointer then
we've got a problem so we should
probably logged this so we'll just say
problem is we'll pass in a name so we'll
do this this will take an A
name and a size which will by default be
negative one so negative one means the
size wasn't specified or something
so we'll do something like
now font and then fonts equals name and
then we'll say if size doesn't equal
negative one or size is greater than
zero you can't have a zero sized font
and I think so if that is greater than
zero then we'll say size equals that's
annoying okay we'll split this up sighs
it was size so we'll do that else
nothing and I will do the same thing at
this time weight just shuffling sighs
see that's gone it that's that's why I
thought it'd be annoying and it is
because the different types okay yeah
yeah whatever we'll just um I'll just
say if size greater than zero size
ok so now we've got a decent like log of
what happens if the font could not pass
validation so at least it's telling us
and then what will happen if that
happens by the way so font manager the
first time we try and add some facts
this should just happen upon starting
right so what should happen is when we
start our game the window will need a
font so what will happen is what window
will do is when it starts if everything
goes correctly and this returns true
which will be the case we're going to go
ahead and say font manager add and then
new font and this will be that font
thing this basically it will do this so
there'll be a default font because
that's kind of important oh we can all
be just get the file manager to get
cleaned up upon exit we'll still make it
public but yeah that would be well when
the window closes that's probably better
I think ok so it will add this stuff so
that we can do that so that it can print
log messages and whatever but this will
be interesting I think because what will
happen is if we do something like that
what we'll do is we'll change will
simply change this to something that it
knows exists so we're actually handling
this this is actually going to be quite
a nice episode because we're actually
doing like proper work I guess M font
equals font manager get source sans Pro
what's that and font what's that yeah
that's that's good and that returned
want no its Const that's not make it
constant and also let's just refactor
this a little bit to say that if it
doesn't ankle not pointer just return
now where we get the whole function to
ourselves okay now we go so it'll set a
default font which is nice and if we
really wanted to we could we could also
get it to change our text to be like
could not load font so that would be
interesting but we've kind of given a a
good scenario here so if we launch this
it won't crash or anything it will still
work but it will print out null font
font Eagles saw sounds pro so you can
see couldn't find that font
alternatively if we do use the correct
phone but we specify size such as 50
that doesn't exist it will tell us yeah
font tickles all sounds per size equals
15 so that's good we've got some decent
logging now for the font manager I think
yeah so pretty good any questions leave
them in the comments below and I guess
we'll move on to the next episode is
there anything else I wanted to cover oh
really so yeah you can you can add a few
different things and I specifically used
a size that that doesn't work so great
alright let's build it for both debug
and release okay and we will push it so
thanks for watching I hope you guys
enjoy this episode I'll see you next
time when we do audio so that should be
fun
actually wait a minute no no that's fine
I thought that was a real error message
but it's not goodbye